movement the a is you're trying to
slowly you're trying to get this
connected with your hip and then you
take it all the way around with
your what most of you doing is even
though you're get here about there it's
it breaks away that the hips there and
then you bring your hand there cu the
desire to do the color G is more
important to you than feeling the flow
of the mov
that's right like I said you got to look
long term you don't PCH things it now
but when you you don't just see a high
ranked teacher gives you it you got it
like that they won't be high ranked
would
they get it that so this has to go all
the way around until my hit decides that
stop
G you say I don't have the wand that you
got and that's that's the difference
between I can
more you
you you you
think I'm thinking of that this leg here
so the first one was here I like to kick
this this make it do
that yes I like this yes I like this so
you have to power it yourself then you
got electric
bicycle and then you s you've got this
this people you
go so you now added an idea to keep you
motivating the next one is
here you think the
motivation you go here's my hand
you there it
goes so you just think about your
hand go there you think your hands going
there and you bring it up there want to
turn the body you
think you see so I'm doing that but I'm
extending it a bit further because I
need him cuz he will be looking at
it I said earlier you you're looking at
their's and yours and I'm not so
here you
got that's your coward that's what
you've got to call in through
when Danny was deciding to do the
technique over he would have had to put
a stability in his body and go I don't
need it there I need it there you put
this in
there so in a way I'm doing
that and I come
here there it's just like hitting a
quick it's not it's not like he's coming
he's coming I'm going to do it
now watch the
back okay and if you're more advanced
then just do a new as well